can you understand and steal me on the
case for the drug trade on Silk Road
like making can you make the case that
it's a net positive for society
so there was a time period of when we
found out the infrastructure
and when we built the case against Ross
I don't remember exactly
in six weeks a month two months I don't
know somewhere in there
um but then at Ross ascendancing there
was a father that stood up and talked
about his son dying and I went back and
kind of did the math and it was between
those time periods of when we knew we
could shut it down we could have pulled
the plug on the server and gone and when
Ross was arrested uh his son died from
buying drugs until ground and
I still think about that father a lot
but if we look at the scale at the War
on Drugs
let's just even outside of Silk Road do
you think the War on Drugs
by the United States
has caused
has alleviated more suffering or caused
more suffering in the world
that might be above my pay scale I mean
I understand the other side of the
argument I mean people said that I don't
have to go down to the corner to buy
drugs I'm not going to get shot on the
corner buying drugs or something I can
just have them sent to my house people
are going to do drugs anyways I
understand that argument
um from a personal standpoint if I made
it more difficult for my children to get
drugs that I'm satisfied so your
personal philosophy is that if we
legalize all drugs including heroin and
cocaine
that that would not make for a better
world
I don't no personally I don't believe
legalizing all drugs would make make for
a better world can you imagine
that it would
do you understand that argument sure
yeah I mean as I've gotten older I've
started to I like to see both sides of
an argument and when I can't see the
other side I that's when I really like
to dive into it and I can see the other
side I can see the why people would say
that
um but I don't want to be my group race
children in a world where where drugs
are just free for for use well and then
the other side of it is with Silk Road
did uh
you know taking down Silk Road did that
increase or decrease the number of uh
drug trading criminals in the world it's
unclear online I think it increased I
think uh you know that is one of the
things I think about a lot with Silk
Road was that no one really knew I mean
There Was You Know thousands of users
but then after that it was on the front
page of the paper and there was millions
of people that knew about Tor and onion
sites it was an advertisement
um you know I would have thought I
thought crypto was going to crash right
after that like I don't know what people
are now see that bad people are doing
bad things with crypto that'll crash
well I'm obviously wrong on that one uh
and I thought you know Ross was
sentenced to two life sentences plus 40
years no one's gonna start up these dark
markets exploded after that yeah uh you
know some of them started as you know
opportunistic I'm gonna you know take
those escrow accounts and I'm gonna
steal all the all the money that came in
you know they were for that but you know
but there were a lot of dark markets
that popped up after that now we put the
playbook out there
yeah
yeah but and also there's a case for uh
do you ever think about not taking down
if you have not taken down Silk Road you
could use it because it's a market
it itself is not necessarily the primary
criminal organization it's a market for
criminals so it could be used to track
down criminals in the physical world
so if you don't take it down given that
it was you know the central how
centralized it was it could be used as a
place to find criminals right as opposed
to dealers the drug dealers yeah so if
you have the card get the cartels start
get to involved you go after the dealers
it would have been very difficult
because of tour because of all the
Productions anonymity de cloaking all
that would have been
drastically more difficult and a lot of
people in upper management the FBI
didn't have the appetite of running
something like that that would have been
the FBI running a drug Market how many
how many kids how many fathers would
have to come in and said my kid bought
well the FBI was running a site a drug
site my kid died so I didn't know
anybody in the FBI in management they
would have the appetite to let us run
what was happening on Silk Road
um you know because remember that time
we still believe in six people are dead
we're still investigating you know where
the hell are these bodies
um you know that's pretty much why we
took down Ross when we did I mean we had
to jump on it fast